okay  [Applause]  oh  here  one minute  [Applause]  yes sir  two minutes two minutes  [Music]  up  thank you  three minutes  didn't switch me  and remember when colin kaepernick  nailed hmm  america got outraged but colin didn't  kill nobody uh  listen thank you look at that her shirt  that's right that's our chicago sister  thank you for being here sis  jesus christ  five minutes five minutes  [Laughter]  okay  [Laughter]  six minutes six minutes  i see you man yeah  it's so sad it really is  that's right  anybody who don't believe this is murder  torture  need to get down here for eight minutes  and 46 seconds yeah  just like you said how can this not be  intentional at this point  you had to make up your mind you wasn't  going to stay there until then  exactly got in here  [Music]  eight minutes  [Laughter]  everybody  [Applause]  one two three  four five six  seven eight  no justice no these no justice no  justice no peace no justice  no justice